what's up guys i'm back for one more
um that i'll be posting as a scheduled
upload while i'm on vacation i'm not
even gonna lie this one's just kind of
lazy like i'm leaving in a couple hours
and i kind of just wanted to squeeze
something out
so uh yeah fencing tokens let's do it
all right so let's talk about fencing
tokens to start to talk about fencing
tokens we should first talk about i
guess a little bit of consensus and kind
of you know making sure that there's
only one of something in a distributed
system
so let's start by talking about
unreliable nodes
even though
a lot of the times we're controlling
every single node in our system whether
that's you know servers or databases
it's possible that some of them can be
unreliable it's possible that you know
they have the best intentions and
they're trying to work with the rest of
the system however for whatever reason
they're actually operating in a way
that's different from the majority of
nodes and as a result it causes problems
in our system
so what are times where
this might cause problems
well it happens to be the case that
whenever we want just one of something
in our distributed system
unreliable nodes can pose a big threat
for example whenever we want one liter
in single liter replication
just one process holding a distributed
lock in order to make a change to say a
file
or just one account with a given
username
okay so in order to kind of present this
issue and how come it comes about let's
talk about process pauses
so often times um a computer will be
running a given process and for whatever
reason that process will be preempted it
means that the computer is running
something and then all of a sudden it
just starts running something else and
the thing it was originally running has
to pause and wait for the other thing to
finish
what are some examples of this happening
well for starters if you've you know
ever used java you might know that what
differentiates it significantly from
languages like c or c plus plus is that
java has a garbage collection algorithm
and although i think this may be
changing as of recent generally speaking
java garbage collection is stopped the
world which means that it's going to
completely pause all of everything
that's going on and instead just go
ahead and do that garbage collection
additionally some virtual machines uh
you know if you're running a virtual
machine might be moved from one physical
host to another and you know during that
process they have to pause
and then a third type which is even more
simple is just say a user closes their
laptop lid or maybe a mobile phone will
you know hit the power button on their
screen
so for a variety of reasons processes
tend to get preempted and as a result of
that it can cause a lot of issues in
distributed systems
okay so this is pretty lazy of me i just
went ahead and copied the the photo from
designing data intensive applications
but i'll go ahead and show how this
might be an issue
so as you can see here in this photo we
have two clients client one and client
two and they're both going to be
requesting a lock service so this lock
service is basically a distributed lock
which is saying any of the nodes can
grab it
but if one of the clients grabs this
lock service it can be the only one
grabbing it and as a result it's able to
write to that file storage as you can
see on the bottom of the graph so what's
going to happen client 1 is going to
grab a lock service
and what's going to happen is it has
this thing called a lease where a lease
is just a given amount of time after it
grabs the lock and after that lease
expires it can either renew the lease or
if it doesn't renew the lease then
another client will be able to grab that
lock
so it's going to get the lease and then
a garbage collection pause is going to
go ahead and take over client one after
it knows that it has the lock
um as you can see this garbage
collection pause which can take you know
even 10 15 seconds like a really
significant amount of time has now gone
and taken so long the lease on the lock
is expired
then client two goes ahead and gets the
lease because the previous lease on the
lock expires and does so successfully
and as a result it's able to write data
to the storage system
but then client one comes back alive
from its process pause thinking it's
totally fine and it goes and tries to
write data to the storage and boom now
our data is corrupted because both these
processes are able to write data at the
same time and as a result of that
something unexpected happens
so what's the significance of these
process pauses
basically a lot of systems will use a
lease on either you know being the
single leader in a replication setup or
holding that lock and that lease is
going to expire after a certain amount
of time
however a paused process or basically
anything that's been preempted might end
up being just about to go ahead and
execute some instructions then it gets
paused its lease expires and then it
goes and executes those instructions
before checking whether the lease is
expired again because it didn't even
know that the process was paused so as a
result of that we can have
a certain process doing things that it
shouldn't be doing way later than it's
supposed to be acting as the soul leader
or the chosen node so that's really bad
another case is just where the other
nodes in a cluster are trying to get in
contact with the second node but that
second node is currently paused by say a
garbage collection algorithm and as a
result of that the other nodes as a
majority presume that it's dead and pick
a new node to satisfy that chosen one or
leader position only for the other node
to come back and now thinking that it is
the leader and we have a split brain
situation
so how can we go ahead and avoid this
type of problem well this is where
something called fencing tokens comes
in okay so the idea of fencing tokens is
actually pretty simple and it's
explained very well by this graph
basically every single time that the
nodes make a decision about who's the
leader who's holding the lock anything
along those lines and you know this is
some sort of consensus decision
all that's going to happen is the thing
issuing this decision so whether that's
some coordination service making a
consensus decision or this lock service
they're going to issue a monotonically
increasing fencing token so as you can
see in the graph below
once client 1 gets lease it gets the
token of 33
when client 2 goes ahead and gets the
lease because the lease expires for
client one the lock service is going to
issue at the token of 34 which is one
higher
so now after client two goes ahead and
writes the storage the storage can keep
track of the fact that it's seam fencing
token 34. so now it knows hey if we ever
see right token 33 we can actually just
go ahead and reject that
this is the result of a node incorrectly
thinking that it is the chosen one and
so by doing fencing tokens we can
actually go ahead and circumvent this
process pause issue and the issue of
having like some sort of split brain or
a node thinking that it's something it's
not
okay in conclusion
due to process pauses or even just
unreliable client nodes we can really
only trust decisions by a majority of
nodes in our cluster however that
doesn't mean that individual nodes
aren't going to be wrong at times
without even realizing it maybe
as a result fencing tokens are a very
easy way to ensure that once a system
has reached consensus that other nodes
that you know are not sharing that
consensus aren't allowed to operate um
in their old state so basically what
that means is that you know even if a
single faulty node believes that you
know it is this one thing if consensus
has deemed something else
then the single faulty node will no
longer be allowed to operate as if it
was still the chosen one or the leader
or anything like that and i'll go more
into consensus algorithms in the future
but for now just know that fencing
tokens are a good safety mechanism in
any system that requires consensus to
make sure that once consensus is reached
it's actually upheld by the system
okay this one was pretty quick and it
was a little lazy on my part just by
virtue of not making my own graphs but i
hope it was still useful let me know if
you guys have more questions i can still
answer comments while i'm gone